-Now, I thought I'd share
some of my favorite #WhyIQuit
stories from you guys.
This first one's
from @soupymcsoupface.
[ Laughter ]
He says...
[ Laughter and applause ]
Right? Okay, Brain?
-Nope.
Now I'm Soupy McSoupface.
-Yeah.
-I'll show -- I'll show him!
-I'll show him, yeah.
[ Laughter ]
"You call me Brain, man?"
-"You can't call me Brain
at all, man."
-"Call me Soupy McSoupface."
This one is from @toshoonly.
-Toshoonly.
-"To," like t-o.
-Like "too shoon"?
-Toshoon.
-It's been too shoon.
-Too shoon. Too soon.
[ Laughter ]
Toshoonly.
She says...
[ Laughter and applause ]
-What?!
-Giddy-up! Giddy-up!
Let's go! Come on!
-Come on, Brain!
[ Percussion
imitating hoofbeats ]
-What in the world?
"Come on, Brain!"
-"Don't be slippin'
on that wet floor!
Piso mojado!"
[ Laughter ]
-This one's from @brennancarrow.
She says...
[ Laughter and applause ]
You're next.
-[ Deep voice ]
[ Gravelly voice ] Redrum,
Mrs. Torrance.
[ Laughter ]
This one's from @kschmooze.
That's her real last name.
-Yeah, that's her last name.
-Yeah, Schmooze.
-Kathryn Schmooze.
[ Laughter ]
She says...
-Oh!
-Come on, man.
-That's not good.
-What? Come on, dude.
-Come on, man.
-This one's from
@johnathanyoung.
He said...
-Come on.
That's entrapment!
-Come on, that's catch-22.
[ Laughter ]
Hey, Brain, you got a knife?
-Yeah, yeah, Brain.
This one's from @yzracer81.
He says...
I don't -- I don't know.
-That wasn't about work.
-[ Laughs ]
I don't know, man.
-Yeah.
-This one is from
@captainharris1.
He says...
This place gets robbed?
-A lot.
-I'm getting out of here.
[ Applause ]
Last one's from @verambassi.
She says...
I'm taking off.
There you have it.
Those are our "Tonight Show"
hashtags.
To check out
more of our favorites,
go to tonightshow.com/hashtags.